ariel on va rester dans les femmes et
l'amour on va faire une interview par
amour
ariane emballé ce que par amour comme si
si vous présenteriez des maîtresses à
votre mari est bien tous et je ne sais
pas mais si c'était le seul moyen de le
garder peut-être que je le ferai que ce
beau mais régulièrement
non mais vide alors là je vais plus de
réponse à bernard gimbernat
là
ok c'est beau mais également je voudrais
toujours être la favorite
j'en rêverai je rirais hélas je te
laisse alors est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il
vient de tuer
ah ben ça bien sûr le cacher oui bien
sûr bien sûr a pas de problème à mais
aucun problème et je dirais même ma
jauge et même nom mais je dirais même
que c'est moi qui l'ait tué ah oui mais
on le sait magnifie qu'il a une chance
en corner c'est le plus veinard de
l'avant les gens qui est ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à vous mettre à
la drogue ou l'arrêter
je dirais que je serai tout pour d'abord
en dissuader lundi 10 mai mais je crois
que par amour ou on est prêt à tout
d'ailleurs
moi je me souviens voyez dans dans mon
enfance où j'habite et le mexique
alors je me rappelle que mon père avait
fait prendre des champignons
hallucinogènes à ma mère est donc
finalement oui ne fait pas une école et
cantine et rennes ndlr elle avait essayé
donc et je crois que lui avait fait un
trait merveilleux voyage de champignons
hallucinogènes et elle par amour avait
suivi et je pense que ça c'était assez
mal passé pour elle voit la passe que
par amour vous feriez la lessive ariel à
votre avis est-ce que par un mot vous
seriez prête à prendre 17 kg oui bien
sûr mais bon si bernard henri pensée
cyber larrory temps qui rigole ça va
mais non mais mais s'il avait envie tout
à coup d'une femme à tresques oui oui
voilà un beau zéro il veut dire eh bien
je prendrai les dix étudiants mais je
crois que c'est faisable mais je l'avais
dit l'amiral j'ai vu quand même à quel
point les allées et dévoué à son amour
né mais je suis sûr que c'est
l'adaptation féminine qui est ordinaire
et extraordinaire ariel est ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à vivre avec bernard
et la maîtresse que vous lui auriez
présenter je sais pas j'ai j'ai connu un
cas où un homme vivait en effet avec sa
femme et sa maîtresse oui
rien qu'a voulu dire proche proche de
vous oui des gens connus non mais
attends que des gens proches de vous
sérieusement en réalité à un moment
donné
bon j'ai habité le mexique et mon père
était un très grand séducteur rebeaud
peur très bon très beau et un moment
donné mais j'étais très enfants est très
petit alors je ne suis pas sûr j'ai
capté des choses mais peut-être pas
vraiment mais il y avait une femme qui
était la dernière se disait la dernière
descendante dernier empereur aztèque qui
s'appelait saute schild qui était une
ravissante métisse aux cheveux tous
tirés en arrière extraordinairement
belle et qui habitait chez moi au dessus
de ma chambre d'ailleurs et ma mère
était vivante et donc je me suis
toujours posé des question de comment
est ce que cette femme vivait à nous
cette mère l'a accepté ça en fait je ne
sais pas ouais et donc est ce que moi je
serai capable je sais pas mais tout ça
est en même temps vous savez très très
douloureux
c'est parce que on est très amoureux
sont même bien sûr paris c'est bien tout
l'idée de cette interview c'est par
amour est-ce que par amour par exemple
vous seriez prête à vendre votre corps
si bernard henri lévy vous le demandez à
des qualités un patient alors je dirais
d'abord je ne suis pas achetable ouais
non quand on aura dit le prix
quel prix du métal la banane est ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à ne pas
faire l'amour pendant trois ans alors
c'est david commence maintenant
renault leur besace et c'est terrible
parce qu'en effet mais vous voyez quand
on lit les grands mystiques toi-même et
saufs à inès de la cruz
par exemple au hasard os d'apple
je pense qu'on arrive à un certain
plaisir dans l'abstinence aussi la
lectrice moi ce qu'on appelle oui et je
pense qu'il ya une forme d'extase aussi
de désiré et de se dire non je suis plus
fort que mot désir je ne je ne cède pas
je reste comme ça et en maîtrise de
moi-même trois ans et alcan oui je sais
c'est le gaz elle et moi non mais mais
mais peut-être qu'on arrive à une sortie
de forme d'extase de douleur ou alors tu
peux passer en manuel non je reviens
bien où vous vous croyez vous à ça vous
voyez ce qu'elle dit là que l'abstinence
amène avec stase amiral ça serait quand
même ça peut être une satisfaction
nous ne sommes pas des animaux voilà si
si nous sommes des manigances pas ça du
tout sera peut-être des mammifères nous
ne sommes pas des animaux ils ont fermé
on peut aussi simplement fantasme est
très très fort et on est dans une sorte
de rêve éveillé dans l'imaginaire et
avoir une sorte de forme d'extase géant
les champignons toujours